right now it's time for WTF what the
failure joining me now Jimmy Fallon host
of fox Across America Jimmy all right
the foreign
Australian prime minister a woman had
some trouble answering a little question
watch
what is a woman I'm very happy to answer
your question in the UK
this has turned into a kind of gotchu
parlor game and I think we've just got
to move away from all of that
Jimmy um would you have
we do have a problem answering that
question tonight
no not according to the videos in my
search history good goodness uh but
stick with me Laura uh she needs to be
careful because if she keeps failing to
Define what a woman is the Democrats
will put her on the Supreme Court
this is the dumbest time there's ever
been to be alive because people who
legitimately consider themselves
feminists have declared war on
themselves here it is really quickly we
could go through the clinical definition
of an adult human female but what
everybody at home needs to know is
there's women and people who dress like
women but dressing like one doesn't make
you one okay I was Superman for
Halloween three times my mom never threw
me off the house because she knew I
couldn't fly why because I wasn't
Superman yeah I don't doubt she wanted
to but the point is it didn't make me
Superman just to put on the costume
Laura
Jimmy we've also heard a lot about the
Biden brand lately they're really
selling this Biden brand but I'm not
sure just like with a woman question
some people just don't know what the
Biden brand is so our own peter Ducey he
tried to get some answers watch this
Devin Archer talks about HAL he and
Hunter Biden tried to profit off the
Biden brand what is the Biden brand
it's gonna get into it from here I'm not
going to get into it from here we're
gonna move on
Jimmy she needed to buy a vowel on that
she even she doesn't know what the Biden
brand is other than maybe Decline and
despair
well listen they're getting 500 000 for
a painting and uh if you think the price
is high you should meet the painter oh
my goodness I guess over the course of
the last month if I had to answer this
question I would think the Biden brand
was a travel agency that books Beach
getaways because every time I see them
Joe's on the beach shirtless eating an
ice cream cone Hunters naked somewhere
on the internet they're kind of like an
all-inclusive I think is what you'd call
it but I don't know that that's what the
oligarchs and the Ukrainian power
companies were paying for the Biden
brand as you know is an influence
pedaling scheme and I'm glad The Jig Is
Almost up right down to the fake names
they use in their email accounts all
right Jimmy I mean come on that's the
class That's a classic isn't it um by
the way the vine Administration also I
think they may have realized that they
haven't sucked all the happiness from
Americans because they announced that
they might go down to a guideline of two
beers per week to stay healthy
so the ceiling fans Lawns cars gas
stoves but touch America's beer what
happens then
thank you and it's easy for this White
House to ban beer because they've got
cocaine okay the rest of us don't have
bags of cocaine flying around like the
White House does so shame on them to
come after our beer are you kidding me
but I gotta be honest with you I don't
for a second think Joe Biden could you
imagine drinking at the White House you
got to give 10 of your beer to the big
guy and how would we even know if he was
drunk like he's already shaking hands
with invisible people and sniffing
babies okay I sincerely doubt he's
drinking so this is another example of
Democrats passing guidance that doesn't
affect them it's a scam Ingram it's a
scam Jimmy you know I don't think
nitroglycerin do they still give that
for heart conditions and beer I don't
think you could take both at the same
time there's some kind of weird
reactions he's not a beer guy I think we
can we can get this warm milk at night
with a half a banana all right Jimmy
great to see you as always